Speaker 1: We knew and we said it was going
to take a while to learn the full scope of
the corruption and attempted coercion and
possible criminality of the last administration,
we knew we certainly didn't know everything
on January 20th when Donald Trump left office.
And just about every week, certainly every
month, we have learned more and more in particular
about the efforts that the Trump administration
went to to try to steal the 2020 election
in the period between November and January.
There is a stunning, stunning new report from
The New York Times, where it is now known
that Donald Trump went to the Justice Department
and press them to declare the election results
corrupt.
Trump wanted them to say this was a corrupt
election to then allow Trump to.
We don't even know.
That's the really scary part.
Let's look at this important article.
President Donald Trump pressed top Justice
Department officials late last year to declare
that the election was corrupt even though
they had found no instances of widespread
fraud.
So he and his allies in Congress could use
the assertion to try to overturn the results.
According to new documents provided to lawmakers,
the demands were an extraordinary instance
of a president interfering with an agency
that is typically more independent from the
White House to advance his personal agenda.
They are also the latest example of Trump's
wide ranging campaign during his final weeks
in office to delegitimize the election results.
Remember William Barr said.
In an interview, and certainly privately as
well, we found no evidence that fraud or improper
actions related to the election impacted the
results in any way, that that's what the DOJ
actually found.
The article goes on to say that, listen to
this, the exchange unfolded during a phone
call on December 27th in which Trump pressed
the acting attorney general, Jeffrey Rosen,
and his deputy, Richard Donahue, on voter
fraud claims that the Justice Department had
found no evidence for Mr. Donahue warned that
the department had no power to change the
outcome of the election.
How many people told Trump that pense DOJ?
Trump replied, he did not expect that.
According to notes Mr. Donohue took memorializing
the conversation.
Just say the election was corrupt and leave
the rest to me and to congressional allies,
Donahue wrote in summarizing Trump's response.
Trump was hoping that if the DOJ could just
say it was all corrupt, then Trump and his
Republican friends would figure out some way
to use that to, I guess, try to prevent Joe
Biden from actually taking office.
Mr. Trump did not name the lawmakers, but
at other points during the call, he mentioned
Jim Jordan, Republican of Ohio, whom he described
as a fighter.
Consider that Jim Jordan was named as one
of the five members of the House that Kevin
McCarthy wanted to put on this commission
to investigate what happened on January 6th.
This is more evidence that Jim Jordan was
more of an accomplice than anything he could
be as an investigator has no business on that
committee.
Representative Scott Perry, who at the time
promoted the idea that the election was stolen
from Trump, Senator Ron Johnson, who Trump
praised for getting to the bottom of things.
Mr. Jordan and Mr. Johnson denied any role
in Trump's efforts to pressure the Justice
Department.
Russell Dias, a spokesman for Jordan, remember,
Jordan voted to overturn the election results
in key states, quote, Congressman Jordan did
not and has not and would not pressure anyone
at the Justice Department about the 2020 election.
Mr. Johnson had no conversations with President
Trump about the DOJ questioning the election
results, said his spokeswoman, Alexa Henning.
She noted he had acknowledged Joseph Biden
as the president elect, but that he also called
for what he sees as a rejection of an erection
election irregularities.
That's my Chuck Schumer moment to be fully
investigated and addressed to restore confidence
in future elections.
Perry did not respond to requests for comment.
He has continued to assert Trump won, but
has not been tied directly to the White House
to keep him in office.
So, listen, I actually don't think there was
really a master plan here.
I don't think Trump has the foresight or the
organization to really do this in an organized
manner.
My sense is Trump had the idea he could coordinate
and put all of this stuff together.
Let's let's get, you know, Rudy and other
people going around making claims and filing
court motions.
Let's get the DOJ to say it was corrupt.
Let's talk about getting people active.
On January 6th. Trump might have had the idea
that he could put it all together is some
kind of master plan.
I don't believe Trump is actually capable
of that.
His general demeanor seems to have been, if
I can just get people, even if those people
don't really have the legal authority to change
anything related to the election, Rudy, going
around, get DOJ to say it was corrupt, get
Brad Raffensperger in Georgia to say we found
these, or maybe he could put it all together,
wrap it up and tie it with a bow and somehow
remain president.
Now, he was probably closer to pulling it
off than we would like to admit.
And what I mean by that is imagine if the
rioters, the terrorists, the insurrectionists
on January 6th had actually gotten to a Democratic
Congress member and held them hostage or gotten
to Mike Pence.
They may have been successful in preventing
the certification of that election for a little
bit of time.
Now, in a sense, they delayed it hours.
They delayed it hours, but not days.
Had they actually taken a hostage, which which
we believe many of them wanted to do, they
might have actually been able to delay it
further and consider how many times Trump
was told by different officials, you're being
told false information.
None of the things you're saying are true.
And Trump still would respond effectively
with I don't care, I don't care.
Just say it's stolen and I'll figure out a
way to use it to try to keep the grift going.
And then, of course, that also gets to what
a lot of this is about, which it's been.
Used by Trump to continue raising money, but
that's the news, the sitting president pressured
the Department of Justice to say the election
was corrupt.
That is an attempt to destroy our democracy.
If he had gotten his way and if he had if
he had gotten someone at the DOJ to say that
and then he had used that to say the election
was corrupt, it's invalid.
And I am going to, what, declare martial law
some kind of state of emergency, whatever.
He was ginning up with Mike Lendell, the my
pillow guy at the White House that day, that
would have been a step towards the dictator
that Donald Trump very much wants to be.
And think back.
I mean, consider what we now know and then
think back to when Bill Clinton had a conversation
with Loretta Lynch.
And that was like a big right wing scandal.
You might not even remember that.
And it seems laughable that that would even
count as a scandal, given what the former
administration tried to do.
It's absolutely crazy.
And next, I want to talk about what's been
going on with the infrastructure bill, which
also sent Trump into a tizzy.